stephen monk any chance the nfl goes to
a neutral warm weather site for the
conference championships that way they
could
go to the president's day super bowl and
lessen the chances of a mid-february ice
bowl situation i don't see the nfl ever
doing it i've never heard any
credible discussion about neutral site
conference championships it's part of
the home field advantage that you play
all season for it's part of what the
team that earns home field for the
conference championship game has worked
for and it gives that team an an
advantage now does it put the best team
in the super bowl maybe not but the team
that has earned the right to host that
game has earned the advantage that comes
from hosting that game so i don't see
that
happening
uh
cj newman interesting question what nfl
player or person have you spoken with
that made you think wow the voice does
not match the physical appearance for me
it's callius campbell a lot of other
people didn't expect patrick bombs to
sound like kermit the frog either i'd
have to think about that there isn't one
that's jumping out at me maybe there's
one that i've forgotten about where when
you hear the voice
it's shocking
and it's not what you expected
i don't know i'd have to think that
through
there isn't one that's just i've been
carrying around in my back pocket yeah i
can't believe this guy talks like that
but uh
i'm sure there's been somebody over the
years where i've said wow that's a
surprise that that's the voice that's
coming out of that human being all right
um
daniel kunimoto if lamar jackson signs
an attractive contract extension without
an agent will be more players lined up
to start doing what he's doing i don't
think so i think that most players
understand innately that
the 100 that they get on their own is
less than the 98 97 99 percent that they
get if they have an agent
and
there's so many other things an agent
will do to help a player guide his way
through his nfl career
richard sherman and russell okung really
tried to start the trend a few years ago
and they were very
they were very vocal about it it's one
thing to say this is what's right for me
it's another thing to say this is what's
right for me and it's also what's right
for you and that's what sherman and okum
tried to get started i think plenty of
guys understand
it's better for them to have help and
what's going to happen is
the relationships between players and
agents will now be created and nurtured
at the college level through the name
image and likeness deals
and that
is is what will
in many situations just become the
natural precursor to the nfl contract so
by the time the players heading to the
nfl
he already would would have been working
with an agent and it's going to be a lot
easier for him at that point to say i'm
just going to keep doing what i've been
doing
jason jones with the nhl expansion draft
tonight for the seattle kraken which two
cities will get an nfl team next and
what will expansion draft protection
list look like i have no idea how the
nfl would handle an expansion draft it's
different every time the priority that
the new teams get in the pecking order
for the draft of incoming college
players is different all the time
but
you know i've always said the teams that
have had successful franchises in the
past are teams are cities that we should
look for st louis and san diego the
saint louis lawsuit
probably will sour the nfl on putting a
team back there however
we have to consider the possibility that
a settlement of
the st louis lawsuit could result in
some sort of a wink nod commitment
that if and when the nfl expands st
louis will get a team
i think we have to at least ponder that
possibility because remember when the
browns
announced their intent to leave
cleveland for baltimore and there was
some saber-rattling about litigation the
end result was cleveland gets a team
a new team an expansion team that will
be the browns that wasn't what art model
wanted to do he wanted to take the
browns to baltimore and make them the
baltimore browns and cleveland would
have been left high and dry cleveland
ended up getting the commitment that by
1999 the browns would be back with an
expansion team so i don't know that that
works in st louis because staying cronky
is on the hook financially for whatever
the fallout is
of this litigation but i'm sure that
cronky instead of writing a huge check
to make the case go away would love
to go to the nfl and say why don't we
just promise these people a team
and uh and then it won't cost me quite
as much to make this lawsuit go away
uh let's see what else we have here a
question from idano40
when was the last time you watched an
old chris farley snl skit that
question's asked because i used a chris
farley gif
from when he's the motivational speaker
it's go time i can't remember when i
last watched one i think the last one i
watched was the the the the uh
lay off me i'm starving which always
makes me laugh but everything that he
did was hilarious i know the last chris
farley thing that i actually watched was
his entrance for a david letterman
interview if you haven't seen that go to
youtube and get it it's magical it's
memorable and it will make you start
sweating the amount of activity that you
see from chris farley in that minute or
two before he makes it from the back
door to the theater
up to the stage i think he takes
somebody out and throws them into a
dumpster along the way but there's a
cartwheel involved or at least something
that looks like a cartwheel but uh
that's fun to watch
uh let's see
what else here we should probably we
should probably cut this off soon
question from yesterday
at milmost with cam akers achilles
injury the rams are in the market for a
running back to help fill the void which
free agent running back is the best fit
for their system and don't say todd
gurley because he's even more washed up
now than he was when the rams let him go
two years ago you know the rams
after gurley and after that knee injury
dating back to college after that knee
started to affect him remember it was
late in the 2018 season a year after he
was the nfl's offensive player of the
year
the rams once they moved on from gurley
pivoted to the 49ers model of having
three running backs who could come in
and do the job
cam makers developed throughout the
course of last season as the best of the
bunch
now look
their plan is to go next man up now i
think they'll backfill with a young
player but they're going to hope the
guys on the roster can
can do what they've already been
practicing to do in that new offense
with matthew stafford there as
quarterback
i
i think that at some point
you know you could see a trade
you could see
the signing of an adrian peterson or
frank gore there's no way
todd gurley will be back with the rams i
don't think he'll want to go back and i
don't think sean mcveigh is going to
want him back but it's a huge issue
whatever the rams do it's not going to
be as good as it would have been with a
healthy cam acres because i think he was
on
track to have a huge season he would
have been one of my breakout players for
2021
and now
that's that's a huge impact for a team
that is in such a good division that is
a huge impact on their ability to win
the nfc west and position themselves to
get farther than they did last year with
jared goff at quarterback this year with
matthew stafford they're going to need
somebody at running back to balance
things out and make the rams as good as
they can be all right that's as good as
we can do
for today we'll be back tomorrow with
another hiatus edition of pft live and
pft
pm sources close to me tell me that at
some point possibly sims will be joining
me for one of these which
good news bad news i don't know the only
way to find out is to tune in if and
when it happens but every day
every weekday even with the olympics
starting we'll have some fresh video
content for you training camps opening
exciting time for the nfl
stay with us every step of the way at
profootballtalk.com and we'll see you
back here again tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports